many of us will be familiar with the
River Styx in Greek mythology a river
that forms the boundary between the
earth and the underworld but how many of
you are aware that Styx was also a Titan
goddess the daughter of Oceanus and
Tethys making her one of the oldest
oceanic sisters she was regarded as the
goddess of Earth making and the river
that shared her name Styx meaning hatred
or to detest the river itself was
considered to be one of the few portals
into the underworld Styx married the
Titan Pallas and together they had four
children Niki the goddess of victory
Zyliss the god of zeal and rivalry via
the goddess of force and Kratos we got
of strength when the time came that the
Olympians decided they would go to war
of the titans Styx was one of the first
stay at ease two pledged her allegiance
to Zeus and in doing so her children
quickly followed suit and became vital
allies during the war when Zeus and the
Olympians finally emerge victorious in
order to show that goddess his gratitude
he gave her name to the binding oath
that will be taken by gods and goddesses
whenever a binding oath was taken they
would have to do so in sticks his name
and the earth would have to be honored
in her waters there is a story where
Zeus fell in love with a princess named
Cinelli who asked him to grant her one
wish
Zeus accepted the princess's request and
took an oath on a river Styx that he
would grant her anything that she
desired Sommelier Zeus to appear to her
in his full glory it was believed that
any mortal who gazed upon a god in their
true form would burst into flames
knowing that his presence would almost
certainly kill the princess Zeus had no
choice but to honor his oath and when he
did finally appear Sommelier and all
those around her burst into flames and
died instantly the god of the Sun Helios
also features in a very similar story
where he Sunfire thong begged him to let
him drive the chariot of the Sun fire
thought was extremely persistent
eventually convinced in his father to
take an oath and sticks his name to
one-day grant his request
when Helios eventually allowed his son
to take the reins the boys an
experienced meant that he bit out of
control and crashed the ancient Greeks
believed that the chariots landed in
in the region of Ethiopia scorching what
was once lush green land creating
deserts and killin all those in the
surrounding areas when Zeus heard of the
destruction caused by Helios his son he
had no choice but to strike the boy down
killing him of a single lightning bolt
in both of these stories the gods took
an oath in sticks his name and made
promises to loved ones Zeus and Helios
one able to break these oaths
despite knowing how dangerous they could
be and in both occasions those involved
diet this leaves us with a few
interesting questions if the gods knew
that only death will occur from these
oaths then why would they honor them
what punishments awaited them if they
broke their word it's believed that the
gods who broke an oath would have to
drink from stix's waters causing them to
lose their voice and eventually being
exiled from the Council of gods the
exact duration of this punishment seems
to vary anywhere from several years to
an eternity but the gods must have
considered them extremely severe being
so unwilling to break their word
regardless of who they harmed Styx was
an extremely powerful goddess and some
believe that those touched by her waters
were gone to danceability the Greek hero
Achilles was dipped into the River Styx
Chur and he's childhood by his mother
making him strong quick and almost
invincible when Achilles his mother
submerged him in the river she held him
by his ankle
meaning the early part of his body
untouched by the waters was his heel
this exposed area would become the
hero's only vulnerability and eventually
result in his death the term Achilles
heel would later be used to highlight
the specific weakness that someone may
have the goddess Styx herself doesn't
feature a great deal in Greek mythology
but the role she played in the war must
have been quite significant to elicit
the gratitude it did from Zeus the start
of the war signals a very uncertain time
in Greek mythology many of the gods and
goddesses were unsure which side they
should align with but Stickle is one of
the first goddesses bold enough to pick
her side and she was rewarded
accordingly mentions of her after a war
are few and far but we know she was
responsible for making sure that gods
honored their promises and kept their
word and for the most part they did fear
in the punishment that awaited them if
they broke their oath
what I find quite interesting is that
the River Styx the domain that the
goddess had rule over appeared more
often in the stories and myths of Greek
mythology than the goddess herself my
interpretation of Styx is that of a
strong fierce and assertive goddess who
was equally as feared as she was
respected but I like to know what you
guys think
do you see Styx in a different way is
she a goddess that you would have liked
to see more off let me know in the
comments below as always I've been your
host mythology and fiction explained